ciao mary ciao edo quanto tempo come stai bene ti trovo bene anch'io ti trovo benissimo
ma che belli questi cappelli li hai tagliati
adesso
eh allora in realtà
li ho tagliati proprio due giorni prima dell'ultima volta che ci siamo visti erano otto mesi
fa no ma ora che allora no aspetta
innanzitutto stai benissimo comunque
sono bellissimi poi volevo dirti che ho visto un tutorial
giusto l'altro ieri di una delle fiale
crescitini sono quelle che ho già
provato e non crescono non crescono i miei capelli le ho provate tutte
ho speso un sacco di soldi e i miei capelli non crescono cresca perché li ho lisci e la mia vita é una merda
che bei capelli posso si certo che belli che boccolosi che soffici che volume vorrei
tanto averli anch'io così ma vai io li
vorrei come i tuoi cioé sono troppo
voluminosi ne ho troppi capito mi
sveglio al mattino e sembro un fungo e no bella
tu devi proprio stare zitta non ti puoi
permettere di lamentarti dei tuoi capelli
quando hai una davanti che ha due spaghi in testa che ha pagato fior fior di
euro per avere un pó di volume sono andata anche
dal parrucchiere di belen niente niente
i miei capelli rimangono così e quindi tu
devi stare soltanto zitta e portare
rispetto
basta mi sono stufata di avere i capelli
davanti con ste due tendine che mi
oscurano la vista quindi proviamo con
delle forcine a vedere qual è il
risultato secondo me molto carino
una esattamente qui perfetto e l'altra
qui top ma come ci sono finite qua le forcine ma non ci posso credere
no adesso me la devo rimettere questa
questa è una guerra
mari dimmi la verità usi la piastra
cioè non è possibile che tu li abbia
cosí lisci io non capisco perché siete
tutti convinti che usi la piastra no
sono i miei capelli cioè io mi sveglio
al mattino mi butto in doccia esco mi
passo il phon e li ho così a leccata di mucca appiccicati al viso che devo fa sono i miei capelli
ma beata te che fortuna che fortuna ma tu hai idea di quello che subisco io tutti i giorni
tu li hai ricci se un giorno ti svegli e
li vuoi lisci ti passi la piastra io
invece no se io li voglio ricci non
posso non posso sono destinata ad avere i
capelli lisci perché qualsiasi piega non
mi tiene mi scende quindi io credo in te
credo in noi capelli miei perché oggi
sarete riccissimi perché dovete volerlo
voi per primi eh
no no stiamo iniziando male vi prego vi
prego
va bene zia grazie mille ci vediamo
sabato ciao ciao ciao mari guarda ti ho fatto
una foto mentre stavi parlando al
telefono carina no bella cioé stai
scherzando
perché questo sono io cioé ho le orecchie
così fuori sembro Legolas sembro un elfo
faccio schifo cancella
immediatamente questo schifo ma io cosa devo fare con questi mi escono le mie orecchie
pure sta disgrazia ma io non ho parole
mari com é che hai tutti questi prodotti per i capelli ricci scusa ce li hai lisci
perché sono stupida perché ogni volta penso che magari comprando un prodotto per i
capelli ricci i miei capelli non dico
che diventino ricci ma almeno un po più
voluminosi invece niente
le ho provate tutte é inutile é inutile
ho speso un sacco di soldi ma i miei
capelli tanto non si arricceranno mai
mari ma non funziona così
ma tu ce li hai lisci li terrai lisci questi sono
per i ricci grazie mille per ricordarmelo adesso
sparisci e portati dietro tutti quei
prodotti che tanto non mi serviranno mai
a niente ok va bene
ok come faccio i capelli oggi
lisci sicuramente lisci
però magari posso provare una riga di
lato così per cambiare ma vediamo
oddio sono tutti elettrici oddio cosa ho
fatto no no con calma vediamo dove si
apre naturalmente naturalmente si apre in
mezzo vabbè dai ho una fortuna mi sveglio e li
ho già perfettamente lisci come sempre
come tutti i giorni della mia vita
sarò sempre pettinata cosí bene